The critics have spoken—and they do not
like Suicide Squad.
"Love your perfume, what is that the scent
of death?
Ha ha ha!"
But audiences showed up anyway, proving once
again that franchise tentpoles do not necessarily
live and die by their critical reception.
That doesn't mean moviegoers loved everything
they saw, though.
As Jared Leto puts in his bid to appear in
Ben Affleck's standalone Batman flick, let's
take a look at what fans think of Jared Leto's
Joker.
"Ha ha ha ha ha aahhhhh"
Laughable Behavior
The story of Leto's on-set antics made headlines
before Suicide Squad's debut.
He's a method actor, so he isolated himself
from the rest of the cast, surfacing only
to send his co-stars bizarre gifts.
"I can't wait to show you my toys"
When it comes to rats, bullets, and dead hogs...amongst
other things...he's apparently very generous.
His behind-the-scenes behavior generated a
lot of hype around his seemingly zany performance,
making it a point of major curiosity—especially
since Leto is known to be very selective about
his acting gigs.
However, many were underwhelmed by his performance.
And one consistent complaint has been that
Leto's portrayal was too over the top.
The Joker is classically a wild card, but
after Jack Nicholson's work in Tim Burton's
Batman, and the legendary interpretation that
Heath Ledger offered in Christopher Nolan's
The Dark Knight, Leto's work was almost exasperating
for those that didn't like it.
Long Walk For A Short Joke
Another common complaint, even from those
who didn't love Leto's part in the movie,
is that he didn't get enough face time in
the flick.
Leto has said that many of his scenes were
left on the editing room floor, which seems
accurate since he's barely in the movie despite
being such a central part of the film's promotional
campaign.
Some fans said they saw more of him in his
music video appearance than the movie itself,
which was disappointing, although not exactly
his fault.
Twitter Titters
Not everyone disliked Leto's Joker.
A quick glimpse at social media reveals plenty
of fans who enjoyed his unique energy, and
who were happy to see a new take on the character.
An unexpected thread amongst fans of Leto's
Joker?
That he was damn sexy in the role.
For some filmgoers, Leto remains a handsome
man, and no amount of grillz or wacky tattoos
can take that away.
Creepy Cut-Up
Another notch in the plus column for Leto
as Joker: the fact that he was, at times,
pretty chilling to watch.
Considering he wasn't even the main villain,
he still managed to freak audiences out, making
good use of his limited screen time.
The Last Laugh
Leto hasn't yet reached icon status as the
Joker in Suicide Squad thanks to his brief
screen time and the mixed fan reactions to
his work in the role, but it wasn't a total
wash, either.
Given a little more time and material, Leto
could still go down as one of fans' favorite
Jokers in cinematic history.
This movie didn't do that for him…so maybe
a turn as the resident supervillain in Affleck's
standalone feature is in order after all.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you thought of Jared Leto's Joker...